hey guys it is the 7th of June today my
name is Jess and as is tradition the
Internet has licked a whole bunch of
things before they can be officially
announced so he is an episode jam-packed
full of those our first leak comes via
IGN who accidentally activated watchdogs
to marketing material which has since
been removed the advertisement revealed
that the sequel is set in San Francisco
and will come out on November 15 also
featured was an image of what appears to
be the new protagonist whose character
model matches up with the leaked image
posted to Instagram in April Ubisoft
announced yesterday that they plan to
hold a watchdogs to reveal event on june
eight so they should still be a bunch of
things to learn if you came to tune in
you can watch the full broadcast on
gamespot switching gears from ubisoft to
warner brothers it's looking more and
more likely that injustice gods among us
to is headed our way a poster which was
reportedly from gamestop was shared with
polygons it shows off the flash and
batman readying themselves for battle
and a tagline every battle defines you
underneath and injustice to logos
earlier this month unnamed sources
suggested that the fighting game was in
development for ps4 xbox one and pc that
report also stated that the game will be
announced soon and released in march of
2017 in what appears to be another
strong indication nether realm boss ed
boon changed his twitter avatar to the
roman numeral 42 and his Twitter cover
image to a drum roll finally industry
insider shinobi 602 has dropped a bunch
of bethesda rumors which were later
corroborated by Eurogamer shinobi has
suggested that Bethesda will announce
prey 2 and a remaster project during
their e3 briefing this year preto is
expected to be reworked completely and
will reportedly have a system shock vibe
the last official word on preto was from
bethesda back in 2014 when they
confirmed the game had been canceled as
for the remaster shinobi had no extra
info to share but Eurogamer have since
chimed in to say that it could be for
2011 skyrim the report made no mention
of a release date but it's expected to
land on ps4 and xbox one in november of
last year
just said they did port Skyrim to xbox
one but only as a technical exercise the
Skyrim remaster project is expected to
include mods all DLC and improved
visuals according to a source from near
gas Eurogamer added that they have heard
bethesda is also going to announce the
evil within 2 Wolfenstein then you order
to and the aforementioned reworked pray
to let me know in that comment box which
of these leaks you care about and be
sure to head to games but where we've
got news on the kajima productions
mascot and ex-con to be sure to pop I
again tomorrow for even more news things
you